ja das funktioniert immer nur in diesem
einen moment und wie gruselig habe
ängstigen ist es dass dieser moment 31
jetzt auch auf den heutigen bühne
funktionieren würde
wir haben die situation in europa und
global das nichts nützt
scharlatane die macht an sich reißen und
wir sind zu sehr mit unserem kleinen
kriegen
solche sätze wie europa ist ein
pulverfass das jeden moment der zündende
funke fallen kann solche sätze sind
gesundheitsschädlich schreiben sie
ruhige sachen ja es ist doch nicht meine
schuld dass die zeiten nicht ruhig sind
es ist immer wo geschossen worden seit
die welt besteht und immer hat es
vulkane gegeben die ausgebrochen sind
lebenskunst herr arendt das ist die
kunst nicht dabei zu sein immer im
nebenzimmer wind schießt nie in der nähe
wenn der vulkan ausbricht stimmt wir
befinden uns hier im berliner victoria
park im stadtteil kreuzberg und werden
heute mit der dramaturgin sascha
marianna salzmann die zugleich haus
autorin am gorki theater ist über das
stück automaten budget von anhand meiner
reden aus der weimarer republik dass sie
für die spielplanänderungen
vorgeschlagen hat
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein allgemeines automaten wie viel geht
es um kleingeisterei das setting ist
eben diese wirtschaft des automaten
buffet während wände bestückt und mit
automaten in den schlitz man eine münze
werfen kann und dann springt so ein
türchen auf und dort ist dann das
wurstbrot sehr fleißig sehr anschaulich
wie an allgemeiner diese kleinstadt
zeichnete der sich der stadtrat der
apotheke der journalist einem möglichen
leute einfinden um eigentlich ihre
kleinen politik aneinander zu fahren
denn ihre kleinkriege zu führen ja ich
habe ihm gesagt wir brauchen keine
chance und insofern fangen wir
vielleicht an einem tableau von gutem
spiel forza und steigen in die tiefen
des menschlichen wesens und die
verzweiflung diese figuren und ich
glaube dass man einfach extrem gute
laune haben wird immer und zwar wenn man
dieses stück inszeniert heute am 30
oktober kurz vor dem zweiten kultur
lockdown sprechen wir mit der
regisseurin barbara frey diana kleiner
stück akademietheater frauen für die
schauspielerinnen und schauspielern ist
es ein fürchterlicher gedanke dass man
jetzt das macht und und dann soll es
plötzlich wie aus dem nichts vorbei sein
also das klingt wie ein treppenwitz man
bringt etwas raus und dann geht der
vorhang runter und das war's so viele
kulturschaffende haben keine arbeit oder
haben die arbeit verloren und wissen
nicht waren neue arbeit kommt und das
ist das ist wahnsinnig bedrohlich und
man hat wenn man selber gerade arbeit
hat und was tun kann
auch das gefühl des extremen
privilegiert science und ich glaube wir
müssen wir müssen alle sehr sehr sehr
dicht zusammen bleiben und
und vielleicht ist es das was was in dem
stück dann auch letztlich das anrührende
ist irgendwie versuchen diese menschen
zusammen zu halten auch wenn es schwer
geworden ist und wenn ihnen eben ihre
ihre visionen und ihre projekte abhanden
gekommen sind
aber sie versuchen so viel wärme
herzustellen wie haut geht und ich sage
das jetzt getroffen an der oberfläche
ist das stück von der arag meiner ja
vielleicht ebenso ein kneipen seliges
trinkt und es stück aber das ist
wirklich nur die oberfläche im grunde
geht es ja um was anderes und es geht
auch nicht um ums konsumieren von bier
und wurst sondern eigentlich um eine
gruppe von menschen die die orientierung
verloren haben
sie haben dann sowas auch die augen dass
wir schon auf die kleine hat mit
automaten buffet nicht ein anti nazi
stück geschrieben das kann man so nicht
sagen sondern sie hat eigentlich was
anderes gemacht sie hat sie sie begegnet
den menschen mit sehr viel sympathie und
sie zeigt eigentlich auch die
hoffnungsvolle seite in dieser zeit der
unsicherheit sie hat kein da kommen
keine nazis vor sondern was man sieht
ist dass es so schwer geworden ist eine
perspektive zu haben und dass man mehr
und mehr angst hat dass man den boden
unter den füßen verliert und das ist
allerdings absolut vergleichbar mit
diesem mit diesen pandemischen gefühl
keiner heraus glaube das was so einer
der hauptpunkte ist dass das stück
seitdem es verboten wurde 1933 nie
wieder in deutschland gespielt wurde
ich finde dass das noch mal eine große
brisanz hat und glaube ich auch noch mal
eine große relevanz hat dass es jetzt
wieder stattfindet weil es wirklich
etwas ist was nicht nur aus dem kader
und verloren ging weil sich einfach
niemand mehr darum gekümmert hat sondern
weil es wirklich ein text ist und auch
eine autorin
verboten wurde und die seitdem mit
diesem text nie wieder in deutschland
stattgefunden hat ich habe noch nie
gearbeitet hat weiß ja gar nicht dass es
ist geld
es wird andere zweiten klimaziele was
sein vater gesagt warum hast du dich
täglich her damit das heißt alle feld du
wirst mich nicht und ich glaube nicht
daran dass man im theater immer alles
auf ein heute münchen muss das wie ein
welt seiten müssen wird die leute so
aussehen wie du und ich und ich glaube
dass es gerade auch über die
artifizielle verzerrung und auch über
eine gewisse form von distanz eigentlich
oftmals viel interessanter ist sich
darin zu entdecken als wenn mir jemand
ins gesicht schreit das bist du sicher
teufel rasse bis in die fingerspitzen
davon verstehe ich das stück von anna
kleiner wirkt sich von der gegenwart
eingeholt
doch wie soll man umgehend mit der
pandemie situation wie kann sich das
theater weiterhin bemerkbar machen man
muss einfach jetzt probieren dass man
relevant und sichtbar bleibt und das
kann auch ganz unterschiedlichen ebenen
stattfinden ich bin wie viele meiner
kolleginnen und kollegen auch sehr sehr
sehr irritiert darüber dass die kultur
in diesen tagen definitiv zu kurz kommt
es gibt keine erklärung dafür warum man
theater schließt ich habe jetzt das
ganze jahr über gearbeitet an der oper
und am theater es wird alles dafür getan
innerhalb des betriebes und in bezug auf
die zuschauerinnen und zuschauer das
dass man safe ist
ich habe wirklich dafür kein verständnis
deswegen hoffe ich dass die politik
schon ein bewusstsein dafür habt dass
wir längerfristig ohne kultur ganz
allgemein komplett verkümmern werden
von eva wir wollen gehen wohin denn per
adam worten oder dahin vier
himmelsrichtungen gibt es norden süden
westen osten
es gibt aber auch noch südost nordwest
nordost und südwest so groß ist die welt
da wird sich noch ein platz für uns
beide finden
hoffentlich hält
[Musik]
[Applaus]